zerstörte festungen am ufer des
mississippi
derzeit hat die gebäude auf dem gewissen
da war größeres am werk
ein beton monster das einer gewaltigen
bombardierung widerstand
der bau ist so massiv den wirst du nicht
mehr los einebnen abreißen in die luft
jagen keine chance
eine unheimliche ruine in der es
womöglich spuckt
der ein oder andere hatte in den fluren
wohl erscheinungen überrascht uns das
nicht weit die atmosphäre wer ein echtes
buch schloss besichtigen will ist hier
richtig
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
an der nordküste von wales steht ein
beeindruckendes schloss
[Musik]
ein schloss wie aus dem märchen ein ort
für prinzen und prinzessinnen
ein großartiger palast mit vielen
zimmern zinnen und unglaublich schönen
fenstern ganz klar da wollte jemand
eindruck schinden
von außen ist es zauberhaft aber geht
man hinein können einem schon schauer
über den rücken laufen
sie wollten schon immer mal ein
geisterhaus besichtigen dann sind sie
hier richtig
gotische architektur verblasster glanz
eine geheimnisvolle ja geradezu
bedrohliche stimmung
[Musik]
angeblich spukt es dort jeder winkel
erzählt von grausam gescheiterten ehen
von fäden oder von kindern die ihren
tragischen schicksal entfliehen wollten
[Musik]
der äußere schein trügt
seltsam eigentlich wirkt das uralt aber
einige ecken scheinen dann doch deutlich
das war mal ein echter prachtbau aber
jetzt verfällt er als hätte ihm jemand
die lebensader abgeschnitten
ein trauriger anblick was ist hier bloß
schief gelaufen
[Musik]
hinter dem verfallenen mauern haben sich
geschichten von großem ehrgeiz vom
familienfehden und von kämpfen auf leben
und tod abgespielt
ohne zweifel hat der bau etwas sehr
befremdliches
da ist geschickte täuschung im spiel
irgendwas wird uns vorgegaukelt
dr mark parker ist architekturhistoriker
[Musik]
seit 20 jahren erforscht er die
geheimnisse des schlosses
eine mittelalterliche festung aus aber
wenn wir uns umschauen entdecken wir so
viel mehr
im inneren verbergen sich hinweise auf
das wahre alter
an den fenstern erkennen wir dass es
nicht so alt ist wie es auf den ersten
blick scheint
die fenster sind aus gusseisen eine
material der standardmäßig am anfang des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts verwendet wurde
wenn das kein schloss aus dem
mittelalter ist warum hat dann jemand
ein vermögen investiert um es so
aussehen zu lassen und mussten sich die
massiven mauern je eines angriffs
erwehren
das schloss wurde 1812 von dem
wohlhabenden industriellen lloyd hesketh
in auftrag gegeben es ist das größte
bauwerk das im 19 jahrhundert in
großbritannien errichtet wurde zu seiner
besten zeit gehörten knapp 2500 hektar
land dazu
viele hielten hesker für einen träumer
tatsächlich hatte er einen kühnen plan
er wollte in die architektur geschichte
eingehen
[Musik]
ich bin verlust seiner mutter zu drehen
sie starb als er elf oder zwölf
er wollte ihr ein denkmal errichten und
sie in der architektur verewigen
es wird fest meisterwerk
die prunkvolle imitation eines bauwerks
aus früheren zeiten
gewicht chaos los
[Musik]
wales ist berühmt für die
mittelalterlichen bogen seiner fürsten
daran orientierte sich hess kef hat sich
ihr baute
er bezog die mittelalterlichen baupläne
und die ihre historische umsetzung mit
ein
es ist ein bedeutendes bauwerk die erste
gotische nachahmung in ganz europa
teske verwirklicht seinen traum aber die
geschichte hat kein happy end eine
bittere familienfehde braut sich
zusammen
kriege werfen ihre schatten voraus und
bald macht sich eine gespenstische
präsenz bemerkbar
in ascot lebte bis zu seinem tod viele
jahre in dem schloss über die erbfolge
gelangte es schließlich in den besitz
seiner enkeltochter
das war 1894
die erbschaft machte die gräfin von
donald sehr wohlhabend wie zuvor ihr
großvater drückte auch sie den schloss
ihren stempel auf
die griffin setzt akzente wie diese
große marmortreppe ihr einfluss ist bis
heute zu spüren
aber mehr noch sind es ihre politischen
aktivitäten die für aufsehen sorgen und
den boden bereiten für das was noch
kommen soll
sie war sehr willens stark kämpfte für
die rechte der frauen sie spielte eine
wichtige rolle in der suffragetten
bewegung für die damalige zeit war das
außergewöhnlich leider führte sie eine
unglückliche ehe ihr mann behandelte sie
schlecht
sie war sehr fortschrittlich und das
beunruhigte ihn er war in
viktorianischer gentleman und wollte das
sagen haben das kam für sie nicht in
frage
[Musik]
1906 tat sie etwas unerhörtes
die verbannte ihren gatten der doch
eigentlich der herr im hause war aus dem
schloss
und damit nicht genug
sie enterbt ihn
die beiden folgenden jahrzehnte bis zu
ihrem tod im jahr 1924 ist die griffin
alleinige schlossherrn nach ihrem tod
wird das anwesen verkauft aber damit ist
die geschichte noch längst nicht vorbei
der verstoßene ehemann gab keine ruhe er
kaufte das schloss zurück
jetzt hat es aus trotz
tragischer weise zerstörte er sämtliche
unterlagen und verkaufte das inventar
zum schluss ließ er seine kinder wissen
dass kein familienmitglied hier wieder
hier leben durfte
der legende nach nimmt die griffin rache
aus dem jenseits
[Musik]
kurz nach auflösung der sammlung im jahr
1928 wird hier auf der marmortreppe
erstmals eine erscheinung gesichtet
später dennoch im garten
besonders bekannt wurde die beobachtung
eines boxers namens randolph toppen
während er im park trainierte seine
weinende frau in weiß auf sich zukommen
doch hatte sie ansprach verschwand sie
plötzlich
trotz anhaltender spukgeschichten wird
das schloss zwischen 1939 und
1941 zu einem ort der hoffnung für
kinder die sich auf der flucht vor den
schrecken des nationalsozialismus
befinden
der zweite weltkrieg stand bevor viele
kinder waren in gefahr
deshalb beschloss großbritannien 10.000
überwiegend jüdische kinder aus ländern
wie deutschland polen österreich und der
tschechoslowakei aufzunehmen
man sprach vom sogenannten
kindertransport die kinder kamen auf
bauernhöfe in schulen oder zu
pflegeeltern
250 von ihnen wurden am schloss
untergebracht
es war natürlich herz zerreißen so
kleine kinder von ihren eltern zu
trennen und in ein fremdes land zu
bringen
die schreckliche wahrheit aber ist dass
viele von ihnen in ihrer familie die
einzigen überlebenden des holocausts
waren
nach dem krieg zündschloss zu den ersten
rand sitzen in großbritannien die der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht werden
bis 1985 dann steigen die betriebskosten
ins unermessliche es folgt die
schließung und der schleichende verfall
das schloss wurde wiederholt geplündert
am ende blieb nur noch eine leere hülle
übrig dann brach auch noch ein feuer aus
und richtete verheerende schäden an
[Musik]
das schloss gerät in vergessenheit bis
ein elfjähriger seinem zauber verfällt
und das märchen eine weitere wendung
nennt
[Musik]
auf dem weg zur schule kam ich hier
jeden tag vorbei das löst in mir den
wunsch aus diesen ort zu retten
deshalb gründete ich eine stiftung
inzwischen leitet marc berger ein team
das es sich zum ziel gesetzt hat kassel
wieder im alten glanz erstrahlen zu
lassen und es für künftige generationen
zu erhalten
innerhalb von kurzer zeit hat sich im
schloss fiel bedeutendes ereignet
hoffentlich kann sich diese geschichte
bald fortsetzen
[Musik]
im geschäftigen hafen von loriot an der
französischen westküste steht ein wahrer
koloss
schon von weitem erkennt man die
gigantischen ausmaße
passt da überhaupt nicht hin einerseits
all die luxusyachten und hübschen willen
andererseits dieses beton monster
wir haben es nicht mit einem einzigen
bauwerk zu tun sondern mit einer reihe
kleinerer identischer bauten ein ganzer
komplex
was für konstruktionen sind das
und welche rolle spielten sie in der
längsten schlacht des zweiten weltkriegs
das ganze ensemble hat etwas regelrecht
einschüchterndes
weitläufige beton kammern schwere
metalltüren was immer seine funktion
gewesen sein mag es musste sicher nicht
bloß den elementen standhalten
daran ist nichts fragiles ein wuchtiger
stabiler bau es gibt ein paar
oberflächliche schäden aber die können
dem bau noch auf jahre nichts anhaben
aber es gibt auch andere
unzugängliche bereiche dort finden wir
hinweise auf die dunkle vergangenheit
des bauwerks
da gibt es einen seltsam aussehenden
betonturm mit öffnungen durch die
lichtfeld
man fragt sich wirklich was das hier ist
[Musik]
und was können uns die verrosteten
schiffswracks im hafen über den komplex
verhalten
[Musik]
wieso liegen direkt davor gesunkene
schiffe hat hier eine schlacht
stattgefunden oder etwas anderes
anfang des zweiten weltkriegs
kurz nach der besetzung frankreichs
durch die nazis beginnen hier die
bauarbeiten
welche bedrohung geht für die alliierten
streitkräfte von diesen betonmauern aus
1940 konnten die achsenmächte ihren
einflussbereich dramatisch aus denen
deutschland hatte bis dahin nur über die
ostsee zugang zu mehr gehabt und gewann
jetzt die französische küste hinzu das
veränderte den charakter des krieges
die deutschen änderten ihren fokus aus
dem weitgehend landgestützten krieg
wurde ein seekrieg mit einem schwerpunkt
auf dem atlantik
dabei ist dieser ort von besonderer
bedeutung
die deutschen betreiben großen aufwand
um ihn zu sichern
von großem vorteil für die nazis und
zugleich gefährlich für die alliierten
war die konstruktion des daches
das dach ist eine gut durchdachte
architektonische leistung
es schützt das innere vor angriffen aus
der luft
der marine historiker christoph syring
hat sich intensiv mit dem bau
auseinandergesetzt
das dach besteht aus drei bereichen
wir sind jetzt im mittleren teil einen
hohlraum
darüber sind beton balken und darunter
drei oder vier meter dicken beton
das dreiteilige design wiederholt sich
in jedem gebäudeteil ein beton rahmen
über einer gut drei meter starten
betondecke
die oberen balken sind zur not
verzichtbar
ein bombentreffer kann sie zerstören
aber nicht den hauptteil darunter
die balken fangen etwas von der
zerstörerischen energie ab und schützen
dadurch den eigentlichen bau
es konnte zwar schaden angerichtet
werden aber nicht an dem bauteil auf
dass es ankam
welche tödlichen waffen wollen die nazis
mit so viel aufwand vor den alliierten
bombern schützen
die deutsche flotte hatte vor norwegen
große verluste hinnehmen müssen
german trotzdem besaß sie eine waffe mit
der sie großbritannien gewaltig unter
druck setzen konnte das u-boot
er bringt das dritte reich seine u boote
in sicherheit
im u-boot hafen auf der landzunge kromer
in loriot es ist die größte anlage
dieser art an der französischen
westküste
damit die u-boote besonders effizient
waren brauchten sie einen ort wo sie
schnell versorgt und aufgetankt werden
konnten das war
unser aufwand wird sofort offensichtlich
der bau ist wirklich bombastisch
hebt sich wie ein gigantischer hugo
tempel und überschattet den kompletten
hafen
wir sind hier im dritten bunker
damit wurde anfang 1942 begonnen
die bauarbeiten für diese riesige anlage
dauerten zwölf monate von visa und vier
weiteren stellungen an der französischen
küste aus wird die schlacht um den
atlantik geschlagen es ist der am
längsten andauernde konflikt des ganzen
krieges und für deutschland einer der
wichtigsten schauplätze
es war eine ganz andere art der
kriegsführung der feind wurde aus
sicherer deckung aufs korn genommen
großbritannien ist eine insel fast alles
musste importiert werden rohstoffe
streitkräfte öl wäre den deutschen eine
seeblockade gelungen hätten sie den
krieg gewonnen
während der atlantik schlacht versenkt
die deutsche marine 3500 alliierte
handelsschiffe
allein in einer einzigen woche zerstören
die u-boote
27 schiffe der royal navy
mehrere millionen tonnen güter wurden
versenkt alles vorräte öl rohstoffe und
leider auch die besatzung
für die deutschen war das ein großer
erfolg
und wenn du mit etwas erfolg hast
investierst du weiter in diese sache
genau das haben sie getan
winston churchill sagte später die eine
schlacht die ihm den schlaf geraubt habe
sei die schlacht um den atlantik gewesen
sie dauerte von 1939 bis zum letzten
kriegstag im jahr 1945
einzige hoffnung für die alliierten die
zerstörung der deutschen u boot
stellungen
ich habe luft bilder gesehen die nach
dem abwurf von 500 und 1000 von bomben
gemacht wurden selbst volltreffer
konnten dem beton kaum etwas anhaben
jedem dach gab es bombenkrater die
eigentliche zerstörung war aber begrenzt
denn trotz der offensichtlichen schäden
war das gebäude an sich nicht betroffen
nicht nur das doch ist praktisch um ein
in bar jeder zentimeter des gebäudes ist
für die verteidigung konzipiert
oben sind geschützt stellungen
angebracht im wasser liegen
behelfsmäßige torpedo barrieren
gebote wurden an strategischen
positionen versenkt kam ein niedrig
fliegender bombe rein erwischte er die
schiffswracks und mich die dahinter
liegenden boote
finden die alliierten einen weg die
stark gesicherte basis zu attackieren
können sie sie am ende gar zerstören
während des zweiten weltkriegs greifen
alliierte flug geschah eine deutsche u
boot stellung an für viele der piloten
eine reine kamikaze aktion
stellen sie sich vor 600 bunker mit
radar funk flugabwehrkanonen dazu der
schutz der see
für die flugzeuge waren das sehr
gefährliche missionen
wir liegen immer noch viele wracks die
von der deutschen flughäfen
wollen die alliierten siegen brauchen
sie eine neue strategie keine guten
neuigkeiten für die stadt lavrion
[Musik]
die alliierten verstanden schnell dass
die ausstellung quasi uneinnehmbar war
deshalb konzentrierten sie sich auf den
ort dahinter
95 prozent der stadt wurden zerstört
häuser wasserleitungen vorratslager
sie kappten die nachschublinien
zerstörten bahngleise und rohstofflager
so hofften sie die u boot stellung zu
schwächen
dem bunker selbst können die alliierten
bomber wenig anhaben die neue strategie
ist da wesentlich erfolgreicher
im ansatz erkennt man einen vierten
bunker der sollte auch gebaut werden
aber das bombardement der alliierten
verhinderte es
der erfolg hat einen hohen preis
hunderte bürgerinnen und bürger von
loriot bezahlen ihn mit dem leben
der einzige weg den bunker zu zerstören
bestand in der zerstörung der stadt die
das war schrecklich
nach dem krieg ist der bunker nur
kurzzeitig verweist bald zieht die
französische marine ein
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg blieb eine
ganze reihe mächtiger kriegs button
zurück darunter diese gewaltige u-boot
stellung was sollte man damit machen
eine zivile nutzung kam kaum in frage
so blieb eigentlich nur die französische
marine sie nutzte den bau noch einige
jahrzehnte lang
inzwischen wird das ehemalige beton
monster für andere zwecke verwendet
verschiedene firmen sind hier
untergebracht
aber auch ein theater und ein museum das
die erinnerung an den historischen ort
lebendig hält
[Musik]
am ufer des mississippi nördlich von
triumph lousiana taucht aus dichtem laub
ein gebäudekomplex auf
der süden louisianas versinkt geradezu
im wasser
und dann ist da plötzlich diese große
anlage
[Musik]
man denkt das muss ein bedeutendes
bauwerk sein granit mauerwerk
betonblöcke da hat jemand etwas richtig
großes hingesetzt
das ganze liegt mitten im sumpf da ist
eine art zugbrücke es muss einen grund
gegeben haben hier etwas so imposantes
zu bauen
geht man über die brücke steht man vor
einem ungewöhnlichen gebäude
es ist ziemlich raffiniert sehr
weitläufig und mit gewölbten decken das
muss ein vermögen gekostet haben
und auf der gegenüberliegenden
flussseite versinkt ein weiterer ruinen
komplex in den fluten
die ruinen sind quasi im begriff ins
meer gespült zu werden sie sind sehr
stark beschädigt
ganz offensichtlich besteht hier ein
zusammenhang aber was ist passiert und
was hat sie verbunden
[Musik]
das ist vor jackson ein lange
vergessenes relikt mit faszinierender
geschichte er trug sich ein zäher
konflikt mit großer bedeutung für die
usa zu
jeans monterrey ist experte für diesen
ort und setzt sich für seinen erhalt ein
wir sind fast 150 kilometer von new
orleans entfernt und kaum einer weiß
dass es diesen platz gibt trotzdem ist
der teil unserer geschichte
das beeindruckendste ist dass es dieses
vor überhaupt gibt gerade hier an einem
ort ohne nennenswerte infrastruktur und
ohne soliden untergrund
ex marin mark sauer weiß besser als
jeder andere wie tückisch der boden in
dieser gegend sein kann
aus dem hubschrauber werden die
herausforderungen des terrors deutlich
gesehen besteht die gegend hauptsächlich
aus dem von kanälen
[Musik]
der welt weitgehend abgeschnitten und
werte erreicht
als die arbeiten im jahr 1822 beginnen
haben die ingenieure einen weg gefunden
um auf sumpfland zu bauen
[Musik]
sie legten ein fundament auszupressen
holz das mag verrückt klingen aber es
funktionierte das holz sank in den
schlamm ein und bildete einen stabilen
untergrund der ziegelbauten tragen
konnte
die anlage ist wunderschön sie wurde von
italienischen renaissance bauten
inspiriert die mit ihrer sternform
damals als sehr innovativ galten
nach dem vorbild 400 jahre alte
europäische anlagen errichtet soll die
form des fußes angreifenden armeen
möglichst schwer machen
der stern brachte zum einen eine größere
reichweite für die kanonen mit sich
zum anderen wurde der gegner gezwungen
einen großen bogen um die ecken zu
machen sonst hätten in die
scharfschützen oder kanonen leichter
erfassen kann
war es wirklich interessant ist obwohl
das vor im neunzehnten jahrhundert
errichtet wurde stand es quasi aus dem
15 jahrhundert es galt damals als
uneinnehmbar
die bauarbeiten sind extrem aufwendig
wer auch immer die verantwortung trägt
will etwas sehr wichtiges schützen der
schlüssel zum ganzen liegt direkt vor
der tür der mächtige mississippi fluss
[Musik]
die bedeutung des mississippi ist für
die amerikanische geschichte einfach
immens er ist wie eine super autobahn
ins landesinnere
wer in dieser region güter oder menschen
transportieren wollte tat es per schiff
oder gar nicht
dass vorliegt an einer biegung richtung
new orleans ein strategisch sehr
wichtiger punkt
und die verteidigung von new orleans
hatte absolute priorität seit die usa
das territorium erworben hatten
er ließ vor jackson erbaut
und vor wem sollte new orleans geschützt
werden
um das herauszufinden müssen wir uns die
verfallenen bauten am anderen ufer
genauer ansehen
wie
sehen sie ihre rechte
runter gekommen
[Musik]
das ist v10 philipp erbaut 1792 von den
spaniern
damals haben die usa hier noch nicht das
sagen vor jackson wird erst 40 jahre
später errichtet
dieser teil des golfs von mexiko war
lange von den damaligen großmächten
umkämpft zuerst gehörte er zu spanien
dann zu frankreich schließlich kauften
die vereinigten staaten louisiana den
franzosen ab so ging es hin und her aber
alle erkannten die enorme strategische
bedeutung
der verkauf von louisiana geht anfang
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts über die
bühne so gelangt dass vor in die hände
der noch jungen usa als die ihre
eigenständigkeit gegenüber den briten
verteidigen wollen wird es erstmals
gebraucht der krieg von 1812 steht
unmittelbar bevor
großbritannien unternahm den versuch new
orleans mit seinem bedeutenden hafen
anzugreifen
bodentruppen rückten vor und einige
kriegsschiffe wollten den mississippi
hinauf fahren aber sie wurden von den
kanonen des fonds zurückgeschlagen an
der biegung des flusses kamen sie nicht
vorbei
ohne die unterstützung vom wasser aus
haben die amerikanischen truppen unter
general andrew jackson leichtes spiel
mit den briten
wären die schiffe durchgekommen hätte
die schlacht einen ganz anderen verlauf
nehmen können
philip hatte großen anteil am sieg der
amerikaner bei der schlacht um new
orleans im jahr 1815 es ist der moment
in dem großbritannien seinen traum von
der rückgewinnung der amerikanischen
kolonien aufgeben muss
was wir in strategischer hinsicht aus
dem krieg von 1812 lernen ist dass es
enorm wichtig war den unteren
mississippi und damit new orleans zu
verteidigen und die fonds waren dafür
unerlässlich
nach dem sieg über die briten ist
general jackson davon überzeugt dass es
eines weiteren falls bedarf um die
größte stadt des südens zu verteidigen
jackson war ein nationalheld er galt als
militärisches genie und als mutiger mann
sein wort hatte großes gewicht und er
hatte ja auch recht es war von größter
bedeutung diese strategisch wichtige
passage zu kontrollieren
was schlägt jackson vor und welche
geniale bau technik kommt zum einsatz
es dauert ein komplettes jahrzehnt aber
dann ist die festung die den namen des
initiators trägt einsatzbereit
ab sofort kooperieren vor jackson und
ford sind philipp um die feindlichen
angriffe abzuwehren
vor 1860 machte der mississippi an
dieser stelle eine solche bewegung dass
jedes feindliche segelschiff einem
gefährlichen bombardements ausgesetzt
war
mit vier cent wird am westufer waren die
schiffe von zwei seiten eingeteilt sie
saßen praktisch in der falle
es gibt eine weitere geniale
konstruktion die die schlagkraft der
beiden fonds erhöht
die fonds waren so konzipiert dass sie
einander perfekt ergänzten dazwischen
wurde eine unterwasser kette gespannt
die im notfall fremde verstappen konnte
die wurden dann von den kasematten
ausgeschossen und im kreuzfeuer
vernichtet
diese vorkehrungen machen einen angriff
auf new orleans und damit auf das herz
amerikas praktisch unmöglich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
drei jahrzehnte vergehen bis vor jackson
und vor 10 philipp erneut zum einsatz
kommen
diesmal stammt der feind nicht aus dem
ausland sondern aus der unmittelbaren
nachbarschaft
[Musik]
zu beginn des amerikanischen
bürgerkriegs war new orleans eine der
größten hafen städte der welt
tag für tag wurden riesige mengen an
waren umgeschlagen
wer den hafen kontrollierte
kontrollierte zugleich die wirtschaft
des südens
[Musik]
1862 kommandieren die konföderierten
staaten von amerika die beiden force
nordstaaten admiral david ferrer glatt
ist entschlossen die blockade zu
durchbrechen
mit 40 schiffen fährt in den fluss
hinauf
eine woche vor der schlacht wurden
lastkähne zwischen den fonds
positioniert sie waren mit ketten
verbunden
girls flotte trifft am morgen des 18
april ein
die schiffe waren mit neueren schweren
waffen ausgestattet außerdem waren
kleinere boote mit masern dabei
und wenn es eines gab womit die force
verwundbar waren dann
mörsergranaten mit hohe flugkurve die
mitten in der festung landeten
rund 1000 soldaten der konfigurierten
haben sich in den fonds verschanzt
nehmen sie unter heftiges sperrfeuer der
beschluss muss schrecklich gewesen sein
8100 geschosse flogen allein auf
vollzeit film
soldaten hatten keine ahnung was
passieren würde nachdem die kanonen sie
gefühlt unendlich viele stunden
beschossen hatten
es war ein höllisches bombardement
pro tag schlugen in den konföderierten
garnison in über 1.000 geschosse
15 mörderische tagelang beschießen die
nordstaaten schiffe die vor
[Musik]
zu ihren kühnen plan gehört auch die
über den fluss gespannte verbindungs
kette zu kappen und sie schaffen s
sie mussten unbedingt an den fonds
vorbeikommen verärgert hatte einen
genialen plan er hätte die voraus immer
weiter bombardieren können aber das
hätte bedeutet gut geschützte stellungen
mit nahezu unbegrenzten waffen und
munition vorräten anzugreifen
so also schickte er seine schiffe direkt
in die flussbiegung obwohl klar war dass
sie dort ins kreuzfeuer geraten würden
sein trick bestand darin es nachts zu
tun im schutz von dunkelheit und
rauchwolken er setzte darauf dass sie es
so schaffen könnten
der einsatz von artillerie im dunkeln
ist selbst für wirklich gut ausgebildete
truppen eine heikle angelegenheit
beide seiten feuerten aus allen rohren
13 schiffe nutzen das durcheinander und
die blockade zu durchbrechen
der weg nach new orleans ist frei für
den süden ist dieser sieg des nordens
eine katastrophe
der sieg bei vor jackson hatte einen
großen moralischen effekt
entlang des mississippi ergaben sich die
truppen der konföderierten es dauerte
nicht lange bis die nordstadt war den
kompletten flussabschnitt kontrollierten
sie konnten jetzt ungehindert weiter
vorrücken
aber was wird aus den truppen die in den
fonds geblieben waren
während des bürgerkriegs breiteten sich
in beiden armen immer wieder krankheiten
aus die sümpfe von lousiana sind malaria
gebiet truppen dort so lange zu
stationieren bis sie angegriffen werden
ist nicht gut für die moral
sie hatten die nase gestrichen voll die
bedingungen waren schrecklich es gab
sogar eine meuterei sie wollten nicht
mehr kämpfen und zogen einfach ab die
soldaten des nordens konnten danach die
force einnehmen ohne einen weiteren
schuss abzugeben
den bürgerkrieg haben vor 10 philipp und
fortsetzen weil überstanden
was verursachte also die zerstörung die
wir heute sehen
seit den 1960 er hat es hier einige
hurricanes gegeben der schlimmste
hurrikan katrina 2005 er zerstörte das
vor sechs wochen lang stand das wasser
sechs meter hoch
vor jackson übersteht den sturm
einigermaßen
vor 10 philipp auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite des flusses
kommt nicht so glimpflich davon
letztlich ist es nicht der krieg der
hier zur zerstörung führt es ist die
natur
[Musik]
wegen ihrer lage am mississippi delta
sind die fonds weitgehend den elementen
ausgeliefert
ford sehen philipp ist so gut wie
verschwunden vor jackson dagegen wird
wahrscheinlich weiter bestehen
[Musik]
wir hoffen dass der national park
service die anlage unter seine fittiche
nimmt sie ist ein teil unserer
geschichte ein teil unseres erbes und
die schlacht war eine der blutigsten des
bürgerkriegs aber es geht nicht nur
darum sondern auch um die menschen die
hier gelebt haben und deren geschichten
noch nicht erzählt wurden
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnungen stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]